Hallo, guten Morgen.
- Morgen, hallo.
Welcome to my new life.
(Lacht) Danke. Warte, ich gehe durch.
TikTok-Star Younes
zeigt uns seine Welt.
Viel los?
Viel los.
Am Morgen ist immer viel los.
Sein neues Leben: das Radiostudio.
Es muss schnell gehen,
Younes darf seinen Liveeinsatz
als Moderator nicht verpassen.
Jetzt habe ich noch ... ein Lied
lang Zeit, dann muss ich reden.
Darf ich dir das so geben?
- Sicher. Hinten?
Ah, du hast ein neues Tattoo?
- Ja.
Was ist es? Afrika?
- Genau.
Wieso Afrika?
Ich stamme aus Marokko. Deshalb.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Muss ich dich anschauen?
- Nicht in die Kamera, wenn es geht.
Bevor ich reden muss, werde ich
nervös. Merkwürdig. Aber immer.
Immer. Ich weiss nicht, wieso.
Guten Morgen. Es ist punkt 8 Uhr.
* Jingle von Virgin Radio *
Virgin Radio Push-News.
Younes checkt für dich
sein Handy ab.
# Push it real good.
* Kreischen *
Schreit alle mal so laut ihr könnt.
Younes Saggara.
Ich habe den Influencer
vor drei Jahren
für den "DOK"-Film
"Generation Selfie"
mit der Kamera begleitet.
Damals war er
ein nationales Teenie-Idol,
bekannt wegen seiner Fotos
und Filmchen in den sozialen Medien.
Das perfekte Selfie.
Mein Aussehen
ist für mich wirklich alles.
Virtuell ein Showman,
im realen Leben aber schüchtern,
braucht Younes die Anerkennung
in Form von Herzen und Likes.
"O mein Gott, Younes, liebe dich
doll. Bleib, wie du bist."
Ich kann nicht ohne Social Media.
Das ist, wie wenn jemand raucht -
man kann nicht aufhören.
Was ist aus seiner Selfie-Sucht
geworden?
Das will ich jetzt herausfinden.
(Radio) Radio Wake Up - mit Younes.
Kylie Jenner: Wahlkampf im Bikini.
Die Jüngste der Kardashians nutzt
ihre 200 Mio. Follower auf Insta,
um Werbung fürs Wählen
am 3. November zu machen.
Ich bin positiv überrascht:
Younes ist jetzt also Radiomoderator.
Sein Bekanntheitsgrad
als Social-Media-Star
hat vermutlich vermutlich geholfen.
Trotzdem:
Er, der damals verloren wirkte
und sich nach dem Abbruch
seiner Lehre zum Pflegefachmann
als Influencer versucht hatte,
scheint angekommen zu sein -
als Host der Morgenshow
bei Virgin Radio,
einem Sender für junges Publikum.
Check virginradio.ch
für alle weiteren Infos.
* Radio-Jingle *
Yay. Das war's.
Wann bist du heute aufgestanden?
Als ich noch in Bern wohnte,
stand ich um 3 Uhr auf.
Seit ich in Zürich wohne,
kann ich bis ca. 4.30 Uhr schlafen.
Das ist echt cool.
Ist aber nicht mehr viel
mit Party Life?
Nein, ich bin alt geworden.
Das ist vorbei.
Jetzt, mit 20, ist Younes seiner
Rolle als Teenie-Idol entwachsen.
Wie geht es ihm damit?
Und wie beurteilt er heute
den Hype um seine Person?
Zusammen
schauen wir uns Szenen von früher an.
* Kreischen *
Krass, o mein Gott.
Ja, das habe ich nicht mehr.
(O-Ton) Er macht ja nur Bilder oder
TikTok - was bietet er euch denn?
Er ist einfach schön.
Und er kann megagut bearbeiten.
Er ist einfach der Schönste.
- Er hat einen coolen Style.
Er hat megaschöne Lippen.
- Ja.
(O-Ton) Younes, der inzwischen
18 Jahre alt geworden ist,
präsentiert sich im neuen Look.
Mit Brille
und frisch aufgespritzten Lippen.
Die sind zum Glück zurückgegangen.
O mein Gott.
Wie habe ich ausgesehen? Ja.
Wir lieben dich, Younes.
Was ist, wenn du mal keinen Fame
und keine Fans mehr hast?
Ja ... Ich weiss nicht.
Das wäre scheisse.
Scheisse ist es nicht.
Es geht mir sogar gut.
Ja?
- Ja.
Krass, was ich gesagt habe.
Okay ... Ja.
Diese Schachteln gehören nicht uns.
Es ziehen gerade alle um.
Auch privat gibt es Veränderungen:
Younes
ist frisch von zu Hause in Bern
in eine eigene Wohnung
in Zürich gezogen.
Marlow?
- Ja?
Das Fernsehen kommt.
Was?
- Das Fernsehen kommt.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich lerne Marlow kennen.
Sie ist Younes' Mitbewohnerin.
Das ist ... unser Haustier.
Im Jahr 2020. Der Staubsauger.
Kommt da noch ein Bett rein?
Ja, ja. Ein Schrank,
ein Bett, das ganze Zimmer.
Wir wohnen erst seit Samstag hier.
Momentan sind erst die Kleider hier.
Das ist das Wohnzimmer.
Wundert euch nicht.
Meine gewaschenen Kleider
trocknen hier.
Deshalb sind sie
einfach auf diesen Stühlen ...
Da ... O mein Gott. Sorry.
Das ist der reale Alltag
bei Influencern.
Nein, hey.
Du bist zu Hause ausgezogen.
Wie fühlt sich das an?
Ich fühle mich megaerwachsen.
Es ist ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass
ich mich sehr darauf gefreut habe,
jetzt aber Bern und meine Mama
vermisse.
* Rufaufbau *
Hallo?
Hoi, Ma.
Hallo.
- Wie geht's?
Ich komme dich morgen besuchen.
- Ja, hoffentlich.
Ja, ich komme nach Bern.
Ich vermisse dich mega.
- Ich dich auch. Ich komme morgen.
Wir sind immer noch im selben Land.
Das Verhältnis von Younes zu seiner
Mutter war nicht immer so innig.
(O-Ton) Younes,
der ohne Vater aufwuchs,
lebt heute gemeinsam
mit seiner Mutter, ihrem neuen Mann
und dem kleinen Halbbruder zusammen.
Das ist auch schön.
Was fehlt ihm, das er hier füllt ...
mit diesen Likes?
Ich denke, eine gewisse Liebe.
Fehlt ihm?
- Ja.
Von wem?
Sehr wahrscheinlich auch vom Vater.
Und Sie haben ihm immer ...
- Ich habe alles probiert.
Vielleicht
habe ich ihm zu viel gegeben.
Ich habe eher Liebe durch Dinge
bekommen, Geld ...
Einfach Dinge.
Hier Geld und dies ...
Ich habe alles bekommen,
was ich wollte.
Von wem? Von Ihnen?
- Von meiner Mutter.
Von der Mutter.
- Ja.
Du hättest aber gerne etwas anderes
gehabt? - Ich denke schon.
Möglich. Ich war aber immer glück-
lich mit den Dingen, die ich bekam.
Ich war wohl zu jung.
Waren Sie nicht da?
- Ich arbeitete viel.
13 Std. -
ich arbeitete einfach immer.
Ich sah ihn, wenn er ...
Im Gespräch verrät Younes mir etwas,
das er damals im "DOK"-Film
noch verschwiegen hatte.
Ich war für ein Jahr und drei Monate
oder so im Heim.
Das wissen mega viele nicht.
Ich war einfach so frech.
Megafrech. Ich weiss nicht, wieso.
Ich war
zu den Lehrpersonen nicht anständig,
erledigte Hausaufgaben nicht.
Deshalb
kommt man nicht gleich ins Heim.
Na ja ... Ich respektierte
auch meine Mutter nicht.
Mhm.
Ich war auch zu Hause frech.
Ja.
Das war so mit neun, zehn Jahren.
Vielleicht wollte ich ...
mich damit auch zeigen,
sagen: "Hier bin ich, schaut her."
Ich wollte Aufmerksamkeit.
Das geht in das hinein.
Das gleiche Thema nochmals anders.
- Genau, vor Social Media.
Hey, du darfst es
nicht zu lange im Ofen lassen.
Also, glaube ich.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wie merkt man, dass es warm ist?
Ich denke, es ist gut.
Du musst es essen, Schatz.
Für dich muss es passen.
Ich esse es nicht.
Ich nehme es raus.
Younes' Sucht nach Likes
und Anerkennung -
ich kann nachvollziehen,
warum das so ist.
Aber: Hat sich etwas geändert?
Ich könnte nie Instagram
deaktivieren oder TikTok löschen.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich bin mit Social Media
aufgewachsen.
Es ist so normal, wie wenn ...
Was war bei den älteren Generationen
normal? Was habt ihr ...
Rausgehen.
- Rausgehen.
Was trinken gehen. Nein ...
- Das machen wir auch.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es
nicht das Wichtigste im Leben ist.
Ich bekomme Bestätigung von
meinen Freunden, von meiner Familie,
von mir selbst - ich weiss,
wer ich bin und was ich kann.
Younes
hat seine Wohnpartnerin Marlow,
die eigentlich Monica Rossi heisst,
bei einem Online-Realityformat
kennengelernt.
Beide waren Kandidaten.
Auch Marlow
möchte mit Influencen Geld verdienen.
Younes hilft ihr dabei.
Mit seinen rund 272'000 Followern
auf TikTok
hat Younes
eine beachtliche Reichweite
und verdient pro Werbepost
mittlerweile mehrere Tausend Franken.
Es ist ein geiles Bild,
aber das Licht hinten ...
Ich will eine Swipe-Story machen.
Dann ...
Das finde ich nice.
Für mich kam es nie infrage,
ein - es klingt doof -
normales Leben zu führen,
mit Arbeiten von 9 bis 17 Uhr.
Wenn du dein Ding
gut vermarkten willst,
brauchst du mittlerweile
eine Reichweite.
Das reizt sie:
Sie will Cash verdienen damit,
nicht unbedingt Fans.
Sie will weder Fans noch Fame,
sondern sie will selbstständig sein.
Das ist, was sie reizt.
Bei dir war es noch etwas anders.
Du wolltest auch Fans
und Anerkennung?
Ja. Das stimmt.
Ich kann nicht ohne Social Media.
Es ist, wie wenn jemand raucht -
man kann nicht aufhören.
Sucht?
- Eine Sucht, ja.
Wonach bist du süchtig?
Danach, mich in der Öffentlichkeit
zu zeigen.
Aber was gibt es dir?
Mir? Ein gutes Gefühl.
Wieso?
Weil Leute Interesse an mir haben.
Dass die Leute sehen,
was ich privat ...
Ist okay, Bro.
Es ist so hart, mir das anzuschauen.
Wieso?
Weil ... das nicht mehr ich bin.
Es ist so krass, wie ich mich
verändert habe. Das ist megakrass.
Weshalb diese Wende?
Weil ich älter und reifer
geworden bin.
Und ich habe gesehen,
welche Auswirkungen es hat.
Ich hatte Depressionen
wegen solcher Dinge.
Weshalb genau?
Einfach, weil ich merkte,
dass mich das Ganze nur verblödet
und mir so viel Zeit raubt,
die ich so viel sinnvoller
hätte nutzen können.
Ich könnte nicht mehr zurück.
Manchmal wünschte mir schon noch
Mama, die die Wäsche aufhängt.
Nein, ich nicht. Ich bin megahappy
damit, wie es ist.
Ich hänge es einfach darüber.
Kannst du das auch ...
Das ist fast trocken.
Wenn es trockener ist
als die anderen Sachen ...
Es schwingt etwas mit, das ich
nun gerne mit Younes klären würde.
Eine Stelle im "DOK"-Film
hat für Schlagzeilen gesorgt.
Wissen deine Fans,
dass du schwul bist?
Über dieses Thema
möchte ich nicht sprechen.
Ich finde einfach ...
Das ist mein Privatleben.
Was dort passiert, ist privat.
Younes wusste,
dass diese Frage kommen würde,
und war im Vorfeld auch damit
einverstanden, es kurz anzuschneiden.
Schliesslich ging es im Film
auch um Sein und Schein.
Als nach der Ausstrahlung
Medien anfragten,
bekam er, wie er mir jetzt erzählt,
kalte Füsse,
und machte deshalb einen Rückzieher.
Ich gebe nicht euch oder dir
die Schuld.
Denn wir hatten es im Vorfeld
besprochen. - Ja, ja ...
Ich hatte gesagt, das werde
ein Punkt sein. - Ich weiss.
Ich wusste immer, dass
du diese Frage stellen könntest,
dass wir darüber sprechen werden.
Jetzt bin ich froh,
dass wir es thematisiert haben.
Es hat mir nicht geschadet.
Ich konnte mich öffnen.
Ich kann nun das Leben leben,
das ich schon immer wollte.
Ich muss nichts mehr unterdrücken.
Ich kann ich selbst sein.
Deshalb will ich
jungen Menschen zeigen,
dass es so befreiend
und so schön sein kann,
sich einfach zu öffnen und zu outen.
Man sollte sich
nicht davon einschüchtern lassen,
was andere denken.
Denn man lebt nur einmal. Dieses
Leben gibt dir niemand zurück.
Inzwischen präsentiert sich Younes in
der Onlinewelt möglichst authentisch
und gibt sich gern witzig.
Er, der mit TikTok aufgewachsen ist,
findet, dass die Kurzvideo-Plattform
sich negativ verändert habe
und zu sexy geworden sei.
Früher war TikTok niedlich und cute.
Kleine Kinder waren drauf.
Alles wurde auf niedlich getrimmt.
Heute merkst du: Man zeigt schneller
seinen Arsch als ...
Man streckt der Kamera
alles entgegen.
Es ist heutzutage okay. Es ist
akzeptiert. Deshalb tun es alle.
Du wackelst auf TikTok auch
mit dem Hintern,
in der Badehose.
- True.
Aber ... Aber auf witzige Art.
Dann ist es was anderes?
- Ich sexualisiere mich nicht.
Also, mit dem Hintern wackeln.
Für mich ist das nicht ...
Soll ich dir ein Beispiel zeigen?
- Ja.
Schau.
Aber mal ehrlich, du bist z.T. auch
oben ohne in der Badehose zu sehen.
Das?
Oder im Pool und so ...
Ah, du meinst dieses?
* Er lacht. *
Dieses?
Ja, aber das ist als Witz gedacht.
Wenn es Comedy-mässig ist,
finde ich es nicht schlimm -
auch bei anderen nicht.
Dann ist es witzig.
* Heller, klopfender Countdown *
* Musik setzt ein. *
Ist es noch eine Sucht?
Younes hat heute sicher einen
anderen, professionelleren Umgang
mit den sozialen Medien.
Aber dem Sog ganz entzogen?
Zwar ist er erwachsen geworden,
aber Younes ist und bleibt
ein Kind der "Generation Selfie".
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020